Husten Schnupfen Halsweh Fieber die Zahl
der viralen Atemwegserkrankungen steigt
laut Analysen des Robert kochintituts
liegen die Inzidenzen der akuten
Atemwegserkrankungen höher als im
Vorjahreszeitraum und deutlich höher als
2018 noch vor der coronapandemie die
meisten Erkrankungen gehen laut RKI
momentan auf harmlose Erkältungsviren
zurück gefolgt vom saskov 2 Virus das
ist hochansteckend und das kommt im
Moment einfach zu dem dazu was wir
bisher schon am Konzert von
atemwegserregern hatten das erlebt auch
der Allgemeinmediziner mal Böttcher in
seiner Praxis in Berlin bei
coronainfektionen verlaufen die
Erkrankungen nur noch selten schwer doch
die Patienten sind etwas länger
geschwächt als bei einer normalen
Erkältung und anfällig für neue Viren
wir merken auch dass Patienten die covid
hatten kurz danach im infektpanel im PCR
Abstrich dann wieder andere Erreger
bekommen das heißt also die
Vulnerabilität nach so Infektion für
andereiger ist auch relativ hoch von
daher würde ich raten auskurieren das
ernst nehmen
lieber drei oder vier Tage länger
krankchreiben älteren Menschen und
solchen mit Vorerkrankungen raten Ärzte
zu einer coronaboster Impfung die
meisten jüngeren Menschen können das
Virus inzwischen gut abwehren die
weitere gute Nachricht es gibt laut RKI
bisher noch keine Hinweise auf eine
beginnende
Grippewelle und aus München ist mir
jetztz geschaltet Direktorin des
helmholzintituts für Virologie und
Professorin an der TU München einen
schönen guten Morgen und ich hoffe sie
sind
gesund guten Morgen Ich bin gesund
vielen Dank Frau pozer also noch keine
Grippe grippeewelle auch keine neue
coronawelle sondern hauptsächlich nur
banale
Erkältungsviren es ist gemischt wir
haben die sogenannten rinovieren das
sind banale erkältungswiiren wir haben
aber auch fast gleich viel inzwischen
schon wieder das sarß Coronavirus aha
und wie gefährlich würden Sie sagen ist
Corona aktuell noch viele Menschen sind
ja dann doch nicht nur ein oder zweimal
geimpft sondern
mehrfach die allermeisten von uns haben
einen guten Immunschutz aufgebaut durch
Impfungen vielleicht noch in Kombination
mit ein durchgemachten Infektion das
heißt dass jemand schwerkrank wird die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist einfach sehr
gering schwerkrank heißt für uns ist
dass man ins Krankenhaus muss und dass
man eventuell beatmet werden muss aber
natürlich macht das Ganze Symptome das
ist eine Infektion die geht in den
ganzen Körper die bleibt nicht nur in
der Nase oder im Nasenrachenraum hängen
und die merkt man die macht einfach
schon krank bei den krankenmeldungen ich
hat es Eingang schon gesagt steUt das
Land ja bis zum Ende des Jahres wohl auf
ein rekordtoch zu durchschnittlich mehr
als 20 viehltage pro Beschäftigter bzw
Beschäftigte müssen wir uns daran gewöh
also immer mehr Erreger und wir dadurch
immer häufiger
krank also zumindest ist es so dass wir
eben im Vergleich zur vorconazeit jetzt
das Saras Coronavirus dazu haben das
entwickelt sich mehr und mehr auch zu
einem saisonalen Erreger das heißt die
Jahreszeit jetzt wenn die Tage kurz
werden wenn wenig UVLicht da ist wenn
man wenig draußen ist wenn es kälter
wird sind prädestiniert für solche Viren
und dann ist es jetzt halt einfach eins
mehr insofern befürchte ich schon dass
wir uns dran gewöhnen müssen dass es
mehr wird als es früher mal war Frau
Professorin in den sozialen Medien wo ja
immer alle alles besser wissen da heißt
es in Teilen jedenfalls durch die
coronaimpfung ist das Immunsystem
geschwächt daher sind die geimpften
anfälliger für fast alles stimmen Sie
dem
zu das ist einfach Unsinn da gibt es
ganz viele Statistiken die sich das
anschauen und die eindeutig zeigen dass
die geimpften besser geschützt sind als
die nicht geimpften dann noch mal eine
Frage zur Impfung die
coronaauffrischungsimpfung aber auch die
Grippeschutzimpfung für wen sind die
sinnvoll für Menschen ab 60 sind die
empfohlen wenn die letzte Infektion oder
Impfung mehr als 12 Monate her war man
weiß für 12 Monate hält die Immunität
ganz gut danach geht sie rund
und gefährdete Menschen sind eben die wo
die Immunität schneller abfällt oder
sich gar nicht so gut aufbauen kann
schneller abfallen tut sie bei älteren
Menschen jetzt ist 60 noch nicht
wirklich alt aber ab 70 80 sollte man
auf jeden Fall drauf achten dass man
einen guten Immunschutz hat und
natürlich Menschen die gefährdeter sind
weil sie Vorerkrankung haben oder weil
sie vielleicht gerade eine Tumortherapie
hinter sich haben oder regelmäßig
Kortison nehmen müssen das sind Gruppen
die sollten auf jeden Fall drauf achten
dass der Impfschutz auch aktuell ist gut
dass sie das mit 60 noch mal korrigiert
haben sonst hätte ich gleich Post von
meiner Schwester bekommen noch eine
andere Frage einige einige Kliniken
haben jetzt auch wieder die
maskenpflicht eingeführt halten Sie das
für sinnvoll vielleicht auch in anderen
Bereichen auf freiwilliger
Basis absolut ich glaube wir haben
gelernt in der Pandemie dass uns Masken
dass uns Abstand halten dass uns das
Meiden von vielen Menschen in engen
Innenräumen die vielleicht no
geschlossen sind dass uns das einfach
schützt und die Maske in der Tasche zu
haben wenn ich in ein öffentliches
verkehrsmuttel muss und da ist es eng
und vielleicht hustet oder schnieft noch
jemand neben mir ist auf jeden Fall eine
gute Idee Professorin protzer vielen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
bleiben Sie gesund alles
Gute danke
sehr